so it took amd six months since the rtx
3060 came out to
finally launch their answer and
this is it the rx
6600xt now normally this should be
exciting but
based on the comments that we've seen so
far
amd's announcement was met with a bunch
of shoulder shrugs and
more than a few angry responses and i
completely get it
especially when you consider what
happened to the arcs 6700xt
which board partners are still having
trouble
selling it anywhere close to what amd
said that it would cost
and let's be honest with a starting
price of 380
u.s this isn't what you'd call an
affordable graphics card by
any stretch of the imagination the other
thing i want to mention right away is
the fact that today is not the day that
you will define these cards
on shelves at least because you'll need
to wait until august the 11th
for that though i'm pretty sure that
some might make their way into
some online sellers today so just keep
your eyes open
anyways i don't want to start this video
on a negative footing because there's
actually a lot to like about the
rx 6600 xd but i also think amd
might need a reality check about certain
things as well
so let's get to that but first a quick
word from our sponsor
you think you can escape brand loyalty
not today introducing the full origin
series of gaming goodies by thermaltake
they have it all to satisfy your gaming
station the full-size keyboard with that
unique dual tone design
the two ambidextrous loaded mouse
options wired wireless
the smooth mouse pad with the rgb of
course the mouse bungie to eat your
cable for control
the h5 headset with powerful high-res
audio and a pretty headset stand to tie
everything together do you even game bro
become an argent yourself check these
out below all right so let's start off
with a bit of a quick refresh about the
rx 6600 xd
so it's the lowest price card in the
current radeon lineup
and it's really meant to target the
1080p gaming crowd
above anything else as for actual specs
what you get is a knobby 23 core with
2048 stream processors and a higher set
of clocks
than the 6700 xt that's a hallmark of
the navi 23 core on both the desktop and
laptop side
and its focus is on efficiency and high
frequencies
now it does get cut in a big way are two
areas
the memory capacity goes to eight
gigabytes and the memory interface
uh gets knocked back to just 128 bit now
remember
the rtx 3060 that this thing's supposed
to compete against
uses a 192 bit wide layout now of course
amd can also fall back to the infinity
cache but it's been cut down
to just one third the size of the 6700
xds
the smaller cache amount is probably one
of the reasons why the board power is
rated
to just 160 watts but let's talk about
that price for a second because
i know it's going to be a hotly debated
topic especially after the
rx 6700 xd ended up hitting hundreds of
dollars above amd's suggested price
even before scalpers got their hands on
it a lot of that was because
prices spiraled out of control from you
know from everything from memory to pcbs
to
shipping so that made it impossible to
actually hit the 480
starting at price but eventually amd did
step in and partially subsidize some
cards right before launch so
they could actually go for the marketed
cost what's gonna happen with
the rx 6600xt is anyone's guess
but one thing is pretty obvious guys if
for some damn miracle
if this thing hits 380 dollars um it's
still 50
more expensive than the rtx 3060 and
that's making a big statement we also
have to remember amd's setting this
up to be the spiritual successor to the
arcs 5600 xt
and to a lesser extent the 5700 but it's
more expensive than both of those
i mean the 5600 xt launched at just 280
dollars
while the 5700 came out for 350 dollars
so yeah there is another hit against
that 380 dollar price
another thing that really needs to be
mentioned is what amd's showing as their
reference design versus the
reality uh for most people i mean look
at this thing
it's so cute and perfect for small form
factor systems
but most will end up looking like the
xfx merc 306 black edition card that i
have here and will be using it for this
review
and let me say this again i hate seeing
efficient gpus like the 6600xt packaged
into
such ridiculously huge cards it's just
so pointless
this one's two and a half slots high and
it's almost 11 and a half inches long
it's actually one of these smaller ones
if you can believe that
i've seen some of the cards pushing 12
inches in triple slots and they're a lot
wider as well
luckily this one looks pretty good with
an overall stealth design and
it's fed by a single 8-pin power
connector so compatibility with
older systems shouldn't be an issue
luckily some companies like asrock will
be scratching that small form factor
itch with cards like the challenger itx
hopefully they will be widely available
at a fair price now coming back to the
xfx card what do you get for all that
size and cooling
well um very little there's a small
increase to the game and boost clocks
and that's about it
oh and there is that nice little 40
increase in the prices
that basically push this thing into the
rx 6700 xd territory now i can rant
about that all day guys but let's move
on to what you actually came here for
and that's performance
now before getting into that i do want
to talk about power consumption because
if you look at amd's numbers
navi 23 is supposed to be ultra
efficient
and that's exactly what it is as a
matter of fact even though the xfx
card is slightly overclocked its peak
power consumption actually came in
under amd's total board power spec and
on average it consumed
just 130 watts which makes it perfect
for
more efficient small form factor systems
minus the xfx card's
size of course compared to the rtx 3060
well it isn't even close at all that
thing sucks back more than 40 watts on
average and even stepping up to the
6700xt will bring you into a
whole different dimension when it comes
to power needs
and with the xfx card sporting the
massive cooler the average temperature
stays
totally controlled at a maximum of 70
degrees
while the fans spun at super low speeds
remember this cooler is meant for
a lot of higher end cards so it doesn't
have any trouble here
and that hot spot temperature is
completely normal as well
that all leads to clock speeds running
along at a pretty constant speed of just
over 2.6 gigahertz but it's
also evident that as temperatures
increase you get a cutback of about
25 megahertz so now on to gaming
benchmarks and let's get started by
walking through 1080p
and the results are pretty
straightforward guys the 6600xd either
ties or beats the rtx 3060
and in a lot of cases acts like a bridge
between the
3060 and slightly higher end cards like
the 6700 xd and the
3060 ti but here's the other thing at a
technical price
and a repeat a technical price of 380
dollars
and the version we have here with a
minor overclock likely going for around
the 425 dollar mark
is the rx 6600 xd really worth the money
for 1080p
in a normal market i'd say its 50
premium is too much against the rtx 360
but
this isn't a normal market by any
stretch of the imagination
so who knows where everything is going
to land you'll also notice i've included
the rx 5700 here as well and there's a
reason for that
from a pricing perspective it actually
started at 350
let that sink in for a second it was
launched a little more than two years
ago but in a bunch of games it still
gives pretty comparable performance
to this brand new 370
gpu that right there is a perfect
example of today's gpu market
if you have one don't get rid of it for
1080p gaming that's for sure
moving on to quad hd and we have to
remember amd said that this is a card
that's
laser focused on 1080p performance and
if you
want to run at high resolution you'd be
better off stepping up to
the rx 6700 xd if you can find one of
course
overall it provides good frame rates
with every game being playable
you can buy this thing and be confident
1440p gaming is possible
but there's something else going on here
as well with only 128 bit bus
amd is hoping their infinity cash makes
up for that bandwidth efficiency
versus the rtx 360's 192 bit
but in some cases it certainly isn't and
in the end the gap between the two cards
become
virtually non-existent here and that
sort of points towards the 3060 being a
bit more of a versatile card if you're
buying for 1080p right now
and want to potentially upgrade to a
high resolution screen in the future
the rx 5700 pulls even closer too
and i'd say that's even more of an issue
since it would stop amd's previous
customers from moving
laterally towards a new card in the same
price bracket of course
there's pretty much no reason to ditch
your 5700 series right now but i guess
the same thing could have been said
about
the rtx 2000 and rtx 3000 series
now we're in the process of updating our
library of ray trace games but
even these older titles the 6600 xt
tends to suffer against nvidia's cards
but look that's to be expected anyways
as more and more titles get the fsr
treatment
this will hopefully improve but until
that point i wouldn't recommend turning
on ray tracing
plus if you saw dimitri's video from the
other day you'll see how pointless it is
in most games right now
or in the case of fortnite it's just
simply broken in the epic setting
so i guess that wraps things up and i'm
gonna level with anyone watching this
video
even if graphics card prices were normal
right now i'm actually not a fan
of amd's offering with the rx 6600 xd
it's being launched six months after the
rtx 3060 and for
more money it barely beats it in most
situations
and they say that it's a day late and a
dollar short there is one shining light
in this whole thing though
while the performance per dollar isn't
great the 6600 xt's performance per watt
is incredible and that's amazing news
for upcoming cards from amd the only way
out of this
is to flood channels with cards near the
mark before the rtx 360 can hit higher
levels of availability
but will that happen well it's really
hard to know but amd needs to do better
since their pricing policies are leaving
cards on the shelves
at retailers that are actually selling
nvidia cards for msrp in today's
environment and given this demand
that's just a disaster so on that note
thank you so much for watching i hope
you were able to take away everything
that you needed to know about the rx
6600xt
let us know what you guys think about it
um are you excited
like are you really excited about this
graphics card
chime in with your thoughts in the
comments i'm amiibo with hardware
canucks thank you so much for watching
and uh i'll talk to you guys in the next
one oh don't forget to spend responsibly